hey what's up guys and Samuel Leeds here
and I had an absolutely outrageous crazy
idea I wanted to get your opinion on
this it's something that I've been asked
a lot about and requested that I do on
my Facebook group and that is this this
is the challenge that I will give up
everything I've got so right now this
mansion where we work from all my staff
my bank absolutely everything
I'll give it up and become financially
free all over again and not only that
but I'll document it and show step by
step exactly what I'm doing
so that's the idea we'd have to have
some serious thought about how it would
work in regards to the ground rules
ie you know I I imagine I'd probably be
somewhere far away from home would I
have to go and get a normal job would I
be just dumped in a hotel somewhere
maybe bought myself a week in a hotel
and then say at the end of the week
you've got to figure out how to continue
paying for it I'm not quite sure how it
work so I'd love to know your comments
and thoughts below on the logistics of
it but also as well as that how do you
want me to document it you want me to
document it professionally maybe get a
bit more videographer to come down or
should I just literally vlog it on my
phone I mean here's my videographer this
is Nick by the way Nick do you enjoy
what you do I love my job what he does
yeah he follows me around videos may say
awesome guy Russell doesn't particular
want me to do the challenge because it
will it'll take me out and he just
enjoys my company just too much what do
you think of the idea bro I think I get
me somewhere far away for six months see
if I can become a millionaire in six
months I reckon give me twelve months I
reckon I can stay in Uganda I mean you
can do a month I'm fluent Uganda on
Monday I honestly reckon I'm not likely
to be arrogant but I reckon you dumped
me somewhere in England you give me you
give me one month
I think I'm financially free I reckon I
can get deals strip you from everything
happy to have an alias name so I can't
even leave rich my brand but here's the
thing if I'm gonna do it I need you guys
support and it's not you're gonna watch
it and Eaton are you gonna share
because if I'm gonna give up weeks and
weeks potentially months of my life in
order to become financially free all
over again literally just to prove a
point and the point that I want to prove
is that anyone can do this it is
possible with the right knowledge and I
read just want to get rid of some of you
know some of your excuses which says all
now is a bad time and no it's harder now
than it was you just got lucky I wanted
I would sort of just spell all the myths
do it all over again and also I want to
be able to be late to some of my
students because now I'm moving on to
bigger deals I'm like buying development
I've got this castle that I've just
bought all this kind of stuff I really
want to just get my hands dirty and and
kind of go back to square one so I can
relate better to some of my students
that are just starting out with nothing
as well so that's the ideas I need so
you're gonna share it I need to think I
like it so what about you student you to
share this video around what heck if I
get enough shares if I have enough
subscribers I want to get up to 10,000
subscribers because right now I'm on
like 8 and a half or something but if
I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna give all
this time up I want it to make as much
impact and reach as many people as
possible so I want to know that you're
in let me know your thoughts below the
more comments the more shares this video
gets the more likely that I'm going to
do it and the harder I want to make it
for myself and just go crazy so look for
10 your thoughts guys be something god
bless